A few years ago Jennifer LeMesurier was watching this PBS cooking show. And this chef, David Chang, started talking about MSG.
几年前，詹妮弗·勒梅苏里耶正在看一档公共电视网（PBS）的烹饪节目。节目中的大厨大卫·张开始谈论味精。
Monosodium glutamate.
谷氨酸钠。
And of course, lots of people believe MSG is bad for you. It gives you headaches, a food hangover-- that idea's been around for decades. I grew up hearing this. Maybe you did, too. But Jennifer knows this is a myth. In fact, the very next segment on the show is science and food writer Harold McGee saying just that.
当然，很多人认为味精对身体有害。它会让你头痛、产生“食物宿醉”——这种观点已经存在几十年了。我从小就听过这种说法。也许你也是。但詹妮弗知道这是一个误区。事实上，节目接下来的片段就是科普和美食作家哈罗德·麦基说的正是这一点。
And he just had this sort of throwaway line that, yeah, this myth of MSG being harmful can be traced back to one letter in the New England Journal of Medicine.
他当时随口说了句，关于味精有害的传言，其实可以追溯到《新英格兰医学杂志》上的一封信。
A letter to the editor in the New England Journal of Medicine.
一封寄给《新英格兰医学杂志》编辑的信。
And I was just sitting there going, huh, one letter. It was like, oh, it's an origin story.
我当时就坐在那儿想，呵，仅仅一封信。这就像是一个起源故事。
At the time, Jennifer was PhD student, very interested in the way people talk about race and Asian-Americans. So to hear that there was once this letter that led Americans to freak out about the dangers of an ingredient commonly used in Chinese food, an ingredient that was later proven totally harmless, Jennifer wanted to see that letter. So she went into the stacks, found this old journal from the '60s, and there it was. A letter to the editor from a doctor, titled Chinese Restaurant Syndrome.
当时，詹妮弗是一名博士生，对人们谈论种族和亚裔美国人的方式非常感兴趣。所以，听到曾经有这样一封信导致美国人对中餐中常用的成分产生恐慌，而这种成分后来被证明完全无害时，詹妮弗想要看看那封信。于是她查阅了档案，找到了这本60年代的旧杂志，信就在那里。这是一封由一位医生写给编辑的信，标题是《中餐馆综合征》。
So the letter reads, "For several years since I have been in this country, I have experienced a strange syndrome whenever I have eaten out in a Chinese restaurant. The syndrome, which usually begins 15 to 20 minutes after I've eaten the first dish, last for about two hours without any hangover effect. The most prominent symptoms are numbness at the back of the neck"--
信中写道：“自从我来到这个国家几年来，每当我在中餐馆吃饭时，我都会经历一种奇怪的综合征。这种综合征通常在我吃完第一道菜后15到20分钟开始，持续约两个小时，没有任何宿醉效应。最显著的症状是颈部后方麻木——”
He runs through the symptoms that he's observed. Then he runs through the possible causes for this strange numbness, and eliminates them one by one. Soy sauce? No. Cooking wine? No. And then he gets to the sentence that's going to live on for a half century. Quote, "Others have suggested that it may be caused by the monosodium glutamate seasoning used to a great extent for seasoning in Chinese restaurants."
他列举了自己观察到的症状。然后他逐一排除了导致这种奇怪麻木的可能原因。酱油？不是。料酒？不是。然后他写下了那句将在未来半个世纪里一直流传的话。引用：“其他人认为，这可能是由中餐馆大量使用的味精调味料引起的。”
And that one line is what spawned this entire myth.
而正是这一行字引发了整个神话。
The letter was signed--
这封信的署名是——
Robert Ho Man Kwok, MD.
罗伯特·何曼·郭（Robert Ho Man Kwok），医学博士。
So the first thing she did was look up Dr. Kwok to get the whole story from him. What she learned was Dr. Kwok had been a researcher and a pediatrician in Maryland, and he was dead. She found an obituary from 2014. So instead, she traced the history of how this letter blew up, led to all these other things, by reading subsequent issues of the New England Journal of Medicine, and newspapers from the time, and other documents.
所以她做的第一件事就是搜索郭医生，想从他那里了解完整的故事。她了解到，郭医生曾是马里兰州的一名研究员和儿科医生，而且他已经去世了。她找到了他2014年的讣告。于是，她转而通过阅读《新英格兰医学杂志》的后续期刊、当时的报纸和其他文件，追溯了这封信是如何引起轰动并导致后续一切后果的历史。
She wrote a paper, published it in an academic journal in 2017. And then after that, she gets his voicemail on her work number. This is last year. She's a professor at Colgate University.
她写了一篇论文，于2017年在一家学术期刊上发表。在那之后，去年，她在工作号码的语音信箱里收到了他的留言。她是科尔盖特大学的教授。
Yes, good afternoon. My name is Dr. Howard Steel. I'm a Colgate alum. In fact, I'm the oldest surviving trustee that's Colgate. And I've been there since God, and love it. At any rate--
你好，下午好。我是霍华德·斯蒂尔医生。我是科尔盖特大学的校友。事实上，我是科尔盖特目前在世最年长的受托人。我从很久以前就在那儿了，而且我热爱那里。总之——
And at first, I'm just like, am I in trouble? You know, why is a board member calling me? What's going on?
起初我心想，我是惹麻烦了吗？你知道，董事会成员为什么要打电话给我？发生了什么事？
I have information perhaps you might like to hear.
我有一些也许你想听听的信息。
And then he sort of pauses and he says--
然后他停顿了一下，说道——
I am the author of Ho Man Kwok.
我是何曼·郭（Ho Man Kwok）的作者。
I am the author of Ho Man Kwok. My brain just sort of goes, what?
我是何曼·郭的作者。我的大脑当时就有点短路了，什么？
And I have a lot to say about it. It just surfaced.
而且我有很多话要说。这事刚刚浮出水面。
And I'm listening to the voicemail in my living room, and my jaw is just dropping. Because up until then, I had operated under the assumption that Dr. Ho Man Kwok was a Chinese-American researcher. And all of a sudden, I don't know what to believe.
我在客厅里听着语音留言，下巴都惊掉了。因为在那之前，我一直认为何曼·郭医生是一位美籍华裔研究员。突然间，我不知道该相信什么了。
The confusion makes sense, because remember, there was a Dr. Robert Ho Man Kwok, the one whose obituary she read. So who is this guy on the phone?
这种困惑是可以理解的，因为请记住，有一位罗伯特·何曼·郭医生，就是她读到讣告的那位。那么电话里的这个人是谁？
I have a phone. I answer that phone all the time because I store the little thing that keeps electrified in my left chest.
我有一个电话。我总是接那个电话，因为我胸部左侧植入了一个能产生电脉冲的小装置。
Then he makes this little joke about how he keeps his phone in his pocket, right by the thing that electrifies his pacemaker.
然后他开了个小玩笑，说他把手机放在口袋里，就在那个给心脏起搏器供电的装置旁边。
So when the phone rings, my heart stops and I answer immediately. At any rate, it would be a pleasure to hear you. Hanging up now. Have a nice evening. Bye.
所以当电话响时，我的心跳停止了，我会立即接听。总之，能听到你的声音真是太好了。现在挂了。祝你晚上愉快。再见。
OK. What? Right? This message was just the beginning-- the very odd beginning of a story that we're going to continue in just a minute. You will hear more from the mysterious Dr. Steel. Because this letter to the editor-- I don't know. Is it possible that this is the most impactful letter to the editor in the history of letters to the editor? It launched an entire MSG scare that lasted for decades. Even today, 42% of all Americans think that it's bad for you, and it's not.
好吧。什么？对吧？这条留言只是一个故事的开始——我们一会儿会继续讲这个非常奇怪的开头。你会听到更多关于这位神秘的斯蒂尔医生的内容。因为这封给编辑的信——我不知道。这会不会是编辑信件历史上最有影响力的信件？它引发了一场持续数十年的味精恐慌。即使在今天，仍有42%的美国人认为味精对身体有害，但事实并非如此。
Since the '90s, the FDA has listed MSG as perfectly safe for its intended use, like vinegar, salt, pepper. Today on our show, we have three stories like this one, where people throw words out into the world that take on a totally unexpected life of their own. And in all these stories, the words wreak havoc for years. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
自90年代以来，美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）就已将味精列为预期用途下完全安全的物质，就像醋、盐和胡椒一样。今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述三个这样的故事，人们抛出的词语在世界上产生了完全意想不到的影响。在所有这些故事中，这些词语在多年里造成了严重破坏。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, Humor is Not the Best Medicine. OK, so where we left off, it was the voicemail on Jennifer LeMesurier's phone from this retired surgeon, where he says, OK, I'm the guy. I made up a fake name. I wrote a letter. And it set off 50 years of completely needless panic over MSG. Call me. Lilly Sullivan explains what happened next.
第一幕，幽默并非良药。好了，我们接着说，詹妮弗·勒梅苏里耶手机上收到了这位退休外科医生的留言，他说，好吧，那个人就是我。我编造了一个假名字。我写了一封信。结果引发了50年关于味精的完全不必要的恐慌。给我回电话。莉莉·沙利文解释了接下来发生的事情。
So last year, when Howard Steel left that voicemail for Jennifer LeMesurier, she calls him back right away, gets the whole story from him. She doesn't record it, though. And a few months later, Dr. Howard Steel dies. But before he died, the Colgate alumni magazine-- remember, Jennifer teaches at Colgate; Howard's on their board-- they did a couple of interviews with him though they did record.
所以去年，当霍华德·斯蒂尔给詹妮弗·勒梅苏里耶留言时，她立刻回了电话，并从他那里了解了整个故事。不过她没有录音。几个月后，霍华德·斯蒂尔医生去世了。但在他去世前，科尔盖特大学的校友杂志——记住，詹妮弗在科尔盖特任教；霍华德在他们的董事会——他们对他进行了几次采访，不过他们确实录了音。
OK, great. Hi, Howard.
好的，太棒了。嗨，霍华德。
Hi. How are you today?
嗨。你今天好吗？
I'm fine, thanks. How are you?
我很好，谢谢。你呢？
That's Michael Blanding, the journalist who did the interviews. He's the one you can hear typing during this call.
那是负责采访的记者迈克尔·布兰丁。你在这段通话中听到的打字声就是他。
I'm going to take you back to the beginning. It was a dear, dear friend of mine and I were recovering from a Chinese meal we had downtown. We used to about once a week, and were perfectly happy--
我要带你回到开始的时候。那是我和一位挚友在市中心吃完中餐后正在恢复。我们过去大约每周去一次，当时还挺开心的——
Howard's friend Bill was a doctor, too. They'd eat, drink, and talk shop. And they got to talking about being published in medical journals.
霍华德的朋友比尔也是一位医生。他们一起吃饭、喝酒、谈论工作。他们开始讨论在医学期刊上发表文章的事情。
Yeah, Bill Hanson, he said, you know, you're stupid, Steel, number one. You shouldn't expect to send articles out and get them published in these dumb journals.
是的，比尔·汉森，他说，你知道吗，你真蠢，斯蒂尔，第一点。你不应该指望寄出文章就能在这些垃圾期刊上发表。
Howard's friend was a doctor of internal medicine, which he was constantly reminding Howard is a much smarter breed of doctor.
霍华德的朋友是一位内科医生，他经常提醒霍华德，内科医生是一类更聪明的医生。
He told me that it was impossible for someone as stupid as an orthopedic surgeon, which I was, to write an article that could be published in something as magnificent as a New England medical journal. That was a threat, and he was willing to make a bet.
他告诉我，像骨科医生这么笨的人，是不可能写出文章并发表在像《新英格兰医学杂志》这样宏伟的期刊上的。那是一种威胁，他愿意打赌。
Bill bet Howard $10 that he couldn't get published there. It's one of the most prestigious medical journals in the world, which Howard took as a challenge.
比尔和霍华德打赌10美元，说他不可能在那里发表文章。这是世界上最负盛名的医学期刊之一，霍华德把它当成了一个挑战。
And I decided, well, I'll write a little article and send it over there. So I went home and I just sat down and wrote a letter to the editor of the Journal of Medicine in New England. And I didn't sign it with my name, but I signed it Ho Man Kwok-- H-O, one word, M-A-N, one word, Kwok, K-W-O-K, figuring that someone, when they got this letter, would realize that what that word was was a breakdown of a not nice word we used to use all the time when someone was a jerk. We call him a human crock of you know what.
所以我决定，好吧，我要写一篇小文章寄过去。所以我回家坐下来，写了一封给《新英格兰医学杂志》编辑的信。我没有用我的名字签名，而是签了何曼·郭（Ho Man Kwok）——H-O是一个词，M-A-N是一个词，Kwok，K-W-O-K，我想当有人收到这封信时，会意识到这个词其实是我们当时用来骂人时用的粗话。我们称他为一个“人类的废料罐”（human crock）。
Human crock. Ho Man Kwok. I know, cringy. An offensive pun on a Chinese name. A white guy playing an Asian for laughs. Keep in mind, this was the '60s. He said he made up the name of Dr. Kwok's research institute and his title, too. He said that Chinese food wasn't the point of it, except for that they were at a Chinese restaurant, eating and drinking a little too much the night they made the bet. And Howard won that bet. Yes, it wasn't an article, it was a letter. But it was printed in the Journal. Good enough for them.
“人类废料罐”（Human crock）。何曼·郭（Ho Man Kwok）。我知道，这太令人尴尬了。这是一个针对华人名字的冒犯性双关语。一个白人为了取乐而假扮亚洲人。请记住，那是60年代。他说他编造了郭医生研究机构的名字和职称。他说这根本不是针对中餐，只是因为他们当时在中餐馆，喝得有点多，才打了那个赌。而霍华德赢了那个赌。没错，那不是文章，而是一封信。但它被登在了杂志上。这对他们来说足够了。
Here's Michael Blanding, the reporter who interviewed Howard.
这是负责采访霍华德的记者迈克尔·布兰丁。
But once he saw it, once the letter was published, he was sort of mildly horrified.
但当他看到它时，当那封信发表后，他感到有些轻微的恐惧。
So he was horrified at first. He wasn't happy that he won the bet?
所以他起初很害怕？他赢了赌局不高兴吗？
It's hard to tell, you know. It seemed like he would sort of go back and forth between being proud of the fact that he was able to achieve this, being published in this journal, and sort of being distressed by the fact that it actually made it into print.
很难说。看起来他似乎在为自己能够取得这个成就——在期刊上发表文章——而感到自豪，同时又为它真的被印出来而感到不安。
As soon as it came out, I called the Journal editor and told him that it was a bunch of bunk, that it was all fake, it was all made up. And he hung up the phone on me. He wouldn't talk any further. He was a jackass. So I kept calling him, and finally, apparently, he gave a message to the phone girl in the office that if anybody named Howard called, hang up.
信一刊出，我就给杂志编辑打电话，告诉他那是一派胡言，全是编的。结果他挂了我的电话。他不愿再谈了。他是个混蛋。所以我一直给他打电话，最后显然他告诉办公室的前台女孩，如果有个叫霍华德的人打电话，就挂断。
So yeah, actually for years, I tried to call him and tell him that the whole thing was a hoax, that it was not true, that I didn't know anything about Chinese, and particularly Chinese-- what's it called? Chinese restaurants. I never saw anybody who had. Didn't know what the hell I'm talking about.
所以是的，实际上多年来，我一直试图打电话给他，告诉他这一切都是恶作剧，不是真的，我对中文一窍不通，特别是中餐——那个叫什么来着？中餐馆。我从来没见过谁有这种情况。根本不知道自己在说什么。
So that's Howard story. And then this joke of his snowballed. After the letter was published, other doctors wrote in, some of them making jokes about this Chinese restaurant syndrome, but also often recounting their own experiences and symptoms. The New York Times notices 10 letters from doctors, publishes an article. Remember, no scientific studies at this point. Just letters, some of them jokes. The headline was, "Chinese Restaurant Syndrome Puzzles Doctors."
这就是霍华德的故事。然后他的这个玩笑像滚雪球一样越滚越大。那封信发表后，其他医生也写信投稿，有些人拿中餐馆综合征开玩笑，但也经常讲述他们自己的经历和症状。《纽约时报》注意到了10封来自医生的信，并发表了一篇文章。记住，当时没有任何科学研究。只是信件，有些还是玩笑。标题是《中餐馆综合征困扰医生》。
The news spread from there, under headlines like, "Kwok's Queeze," and "Chinese Chow Numbs Some." Here's Jennifer, the professor who traced the history.
消息从那里传开了，标题诸如《郭的挤压》（Kwok's Queeze）和《中餐使人麻木》。这是詹妮弗，那位追踪历史的教授。
I mean, the titles were very, very offensive. Oh, let's see. Let me see if I can find the one. From the Chicago Tribune, in broken English, the headline is, "Chinese Food Make You Crazy? MSG is Number One Suspect."
我的意思是，那些标题非常、非常具有冒犯性。噢，让我看看。让我找找那一篇。来自《芝加哥论坛报》，用蹩脚的英语写的，标题是《中餐让你发疯？味精是头号嫌疑人》。
Wow. "Chinese food Make You Crazy"? I can't believe that was a headline.
哇。《中餐让你发疯》？我不敢相信那是标题。
Yeah. So I was like, hm. They were all reacting to something that wasn't even real. It was all projection.
是的。所以我就想，嗯。他们所有人都在对一件根本不存在的事情做出反应。这完全是投射效应。
To this day, lots of Chinese restaurants post No MSG signs in their windows and printed on their menus.
直到今天，许多中餐馆还在窗户上张贴“无味精”的标志，并印在菜单上。
Everybody in the world is talking about the Chinese restaurant syndrome, and it's a lie. It's a big fib. It's the "fit" hit the "shan." It's astounding.
世界上每个人都在谈论中餐馆综合征，而那是一个谎言。这是一个弥天大谎。真是让人震惊。
Howard told lots of people this story over the years. He told groups of other doctors. He told Jennifer, who believed him. She alerted the alumni magazine, who recorded those interviews. They pitched the story to us. And we were like, 96-year-old man confesses to writing a prank letter that drove the nation to a decades-long scare about a toxin that's not actually toxic? He's dead, but you have recordings? We're in.
多年来，霍华德把这个故事告诉了很多人。他告诉了其他医生群体。他告诉了詹妮弗，她相信了他。她通知了校友杂志，他们录下了那些采访。他们把这个故事推荐给了我们。我们的反应是，一个96岁的老人坦白他写了一封恶作剧信，导致全国陷入了长达数十年的恐慌，针对的是一种实际上并不含毒的毒素？他已经去世了，但你有录音？我们干了。
But as we and Michael the reporter started looking into this more carefully, there were a few things that were puzzling. For one, the name of the research institute Howard said he invented-- the National Biomedical Research Foundation-- Michael discovered it was a real place. And the real Dr. Kwok had worked there. Kind of a coincidence, if Howard made up the name-- like he said he did.
但当我们和记者迈克尔开始更仔细地调查此事时，有一些事情令人困惑。首先，霍华德说他发明的那个研究机构的名字——国家生物医学研究基金会（National Biomedical Research Foundation）——迈克尔发现那是一个真实存在的地方。而且真正的郭医生确实在那里工作过。如果霍华德像他所说的那样编造了这个名字，这真是个巧合。
It also seemed weird. If the journal published a fake letter with Dr. Kwok's name and institution on it, and it was quoted in over 100 newspapers, naming him and the letter, it seemed weird that the real Dr. Kwok never set the record straight. Never published a letter complaining in The New England Journal of Medicine, or in any of those newspapers. Also, Howard said he tried to get the Journal to retract it, that he called and the editor wouldn't take his calls.
这也显得很奇怪。如果期刊发表了一封带有郭医生名字和单位的伪造信件，并且在100多家报纸上被引用，指名道姓地提到了他本人和那封信，那么奇怪的是，真正的郭医生从未出来澄清。从未在《新英格兰医学杂志》或任何报纸上发表过信件进行抗议。此外，霍华德说他试图让期刊撤回这封信，说他打电话但编辑不接电话。
We reached out to The New England Journal of Medicine. They declined to comment. But it seems strange just on the face of it. Howard became a highly acclaimed surgeon. He invented important medical procedures. It seems like for sure, he could have gotten the attention of someone at the Journal.
我们联系了《新英格兰医学杂志》。他们拒绝置评。但这本身看起来就很奇怪。霍华德后来成为了一名备受推崇的外科医生。他发明了重要的医疗程序。看起来他肯定可以引起期刊某人的注意。
It's hard to verify what really happened, because everyone involved in this is dead. Howard is dead. The friend he made the bet with is dead. The real Dr. Kwok is dead. But Dr. Kwok has kids. We called them, and talked to his family. We also spoke to one of his colleagues at the research foundation. And the son of his boss there. They all said, yes, Dr. Robert Ho Man Kwok did write the letter. His daughter said he was proud of it. That he was a concerned doctor and a curious scientist, who'd often post questions like this. It wasn't a joke at all. The thought that Howard was going around telling this story, for years, it creeped her out a little.
很难验证到底发生了什么，因为所有相关人员都已经去世了。霍华德死了。和他打赌的朋友死了。真正的郭医生死了。但郭医生有孩子。我们给他们打了电话，和他的家人谈了谈。我们还和他在研究基金会的一位同事，以及他老板的儿子谈过。他们都说，是的，罗伯特·何曼·郭医生确实写了那封信。他的女儿说他对此感到自豪。他是一位关怀他人的医生和好奇的科学家，经常会提出这样的问题。这根本不是恶作剧。霍华德多年来一直在讲这个故事的想法，让她感到有点毛骨悚然。
And when you read the original letter, there are details that seem more likely to come from her father than from Howard, like when he says he moved to the US, which the real Dr. Kwok did, and how he's very specific the syndrome happens with the northern Chinese food. In the '60s, how many white guys in Philadelphia would have made that distinction? Also, Ho Man Kwok is an actual Cantonese name. What are the odds that Howard Steel threw together random Chinese-sounding syllables to arrive at that?
当你读那封原始信件时，里面的一些细节似乎比出自霍华德之手更像是来自她父亲，比如他说他移居美国，真正的郭医生确实做到了，以及他非常具体地指出这种综合征发生在中国北方的食物中。在60年代，费城有多少白人会做出这种区分？另外，何曼·郭（Ho Man Kwok）是一个真实的广东话名字。霍华德·斯蒂尔随意拼凑出中国音节并恰好得到这个名字的几率有多大？
I called up Jennifer, the professor that Howard Steel had left the voicemail for.
我给詹妮弗打了电话，就是霍华德·斯蒂尔留言的那位教授。
I finally reached the Kwok family.
我终于联系到了郭家。
OK.
好的。
And they told me something. They say that their father did write the letter.
他们告诉了我一件事。他们说他们的父亲确实写了那封信。
What?
什么？
Yeah. They say that he wrote it, and they're certain.
是的。他们说他写了它，他们非常确定。
Wow. OK.
哇。好吧。
What do you think of that?
你怎么看？
I honestly have no idea.
老实说，我完全不知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Me, neither. I just cannot believe that Dr. Steel made this up.
我也一样。我简直不敢相信斯蒂尔医生编造了这件事。
Right. Now I'm like, were there two letters?
对吧。现在我在想，难道有两封信？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Did they happen to write about MSG at the same time, and like one got printed, and one person thought it was edited? I don't even know. I mean, I can't really-- oh, man. The timing of this-- I wish Dr. Steel was still alive, for many reasons, obviously.
他们是不是在同一时间写了关于味精的事情，然后一封被刊登了，而某个人以为它被编辑过了？我甚至不知道。我是说，我真的无法——天哪。这件事的时间点——我真希望斯蒂尔医生还活着，显然有很多原因。
There were two options, neither of them good. Someone has been telling a story that's not true for 50 years-- one of these two men, both of whom were, by all accounts, brilliant, upstanding pillars of their communities.
有两个选择，都不太好。其中一个人50年来一直在讲一个不真实的故事——这两个人中的一个，据所有人描述，都是聪明、正直的社区支柱。
Either Howard was fessing up to something he totally did not do, claiming responsibility for the whole MSG mess when actually he had nothing to do with it, or Howard was telling the truth, and Dr. Robert Ho Man Kwok, beloved pediatrician and researcher, had seen this letter to the editor in the journal with his name on it, that he didn't write, was delighted with his good fortune, and rolled with it for 50 years.
要么是霍华德承认了一些他根本没做过的事情，声称要为整个味精混乱负责，而实际上他与此无关；要么是霍华德说了真话，而那位受人爱戴的儿科医生兼研究员罗伯特·何曼·郭，在杂志上看到一封带有他名字、但他并未撰写的信后，对他那意想不到的运气感到高兴，并就此顺水推舟了50年。
I had one person left to call-- Howard Steel's daughter, Anna. She grew up hearing this story. And I told her everything I just told you.
我只剩下最后一个人要联系——霍华德·斯蒂尔的女儿，安娜。她从小就听过这个故事。我把刚刚告诉你的一切都告诉了她。
OK. That is a shock.
好的。这真是个冲击。
But actually, not that big a shock. It took her about two seconds to make sense of all this. She believed the Kwoks, not her father.
但实际上，并没有那么大的冲击。她只花了大约两秒钟就理清了这一切。她相信郭家，而不是她父亲。
No, I don't think anybody who knew him and loved him would be surprised. It's just one more thing in the life of my dad.
不，我不认为任何了解他并爱他的人会感到惊讶。这只是我爸爸生活中的又一件琐事。
This, she said-- this is exactly the kind of thing he loved to do. He liked to prank people. And he told lots of big stories about himself, many true, and some not. You can never totally believe him and never quite not believe him. In fact, she says, it would help explain this other thing, that even though her father supposedly won the bet, his buddy never paid him.
她说，这就是他喜欢做的事情。他喜欢恶作剧。他讲述了许多关于他自己的宏大故事，其中许多是真的，有些不是。你永远无法完全相信他，也永远无法完全不相信他。事实上，她说，这有助于解释另一件事，尽管她父亲理应赢得了赌局，但他哥们儿从未付钱给他。
The fact the bet was never settled up is of suspect, that maybe it was a wink-wink between them both.
赌局从未结清的事实令人怀疑，也许那是他们两人之间的一种心照不宣。
Well, so now, knowing all this, do you feel convinced that he didn't write the letter?
好吧，那么现在，知道了这一切，你是否确信他没有写那封信？
It seems to point in that direction, doesn't it? I think if I thought we were dealing with, you know, two straight laced, straight arrow, no nonsense physicians, I might be arguing a stronger position. But knowing these two clowns, there's not much I can say.
似乎指向那个方向，不是吗？我想如果我认为我们面对的是两位循规蹈矩、严谨、认真的医生，我可能会主张一个更有力的立场。但了解这两个“小丑”后，我没什么可说的了。
So it seems like Howard didn't write the fake prank letter that caused decades of chaos. His prank was that he said he had written the letter. He was claiming credit for chaos he didn't create. It was complicated to even think about.
所以看来霍华德并没有写那封导致数十年混乱的虚假恶作剧信。他的恶作剧是他声称自己写了那封信。他在为他没有制造的混乱揽功。仅仅思考这一点都很复杂。
Oh my god. Oh. Eh, that's too funny. All right, well, here we are. [LAUGHS]
我的天啊。噢。额，那太搞笑了。好吧，嗯，我们到了这一步。[笑声]
First, the world believed MSG was bad for you, and it wasn't. And now, we nearly believed a second piece of fake news-- that it all started with Howard. Here's where Anna came down, loving her father and his best friend, but also, what the hell?
首先，世界认为味精对你有害，但事实并非如此。现在，我们差点又相信了第二条假新闻——这一切都始于霍华德。安娜得出了这个结论，她爱她的父亲和他最好的朋友，但也觉得，这到底是怎么回事？
I wish I could give them both a piece of my mind. I'm not angry, but I just want to say, you owe everybody a huge apology. What is wrong with you? And he would just start laughing, I'm sure. And he would have a big, mischievous grin, and he'd say something like, I don't owe anybody an apology. You all should have had your heads screwed on straight to figure out this was a joke.
我真希望能当面批评他们俩。我不生气，但我只想说，你们欠所有人一个巨大的道歉。你们到底怎么了？我肯定他会开始大笑。他会露出一个巨大的、顽皮的笑容，然后说些像这样的蠢话，我不需要向任何人道歉。你们所有人都应该把脑袋拧正，弄清楚这是一个玩笑。
So many people near the end of their lives are trying to make things right. He was trying to make trouble.
许多人在生命接近终点时试图纠正错误。他却在试图制造麻烦。
Like a last act, like a life-long legacy prank?
就像最后一幕，一场终身的遗产恶作剧？
Kind of. He got the last laugh.
算是吧。他笑到了最后。
I'll do anything you want to with this. No, I'll talk to anybody. They won't believe me, anyway. I'm here and happy to screw things up further. But I can't believe what I did for 50-some years. So I don't know what anybody would want to do with me, except shut my mouth, but it's getting kind of late. God will shut it pretty soon. And you know how she is.
无论你想用它做什么我都会配合。不，我会和任何人谈。反正他们不会相信我。我还活着，很高兴能把事情搞得更糟。但我无法相信我在50多年里做了什么。所以我不知道任何人会想对我做什么，除了闭上我的嘴，但时间已经有点晚了。上帝很快就会关上它的。你知道她是什么样子的。
Howard died just a few months after he laughed his way through those interviews. He was 97.
霍华德在那些采访中笑过之后仅几个月就去世了。他97岁。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, Babies Got Bank. OK, I know how unlikely this sounds, but we now have another old guy basically pranking the world right before he dies, but on a scale that gets hundreds of thousands of people involved, and excited, and talking about this guy's plan that he set in motion for years and years. Stephanie Foo explains.
第二幕，婴儿换来财富。好的，我知道这听起来多不可思议，但我们现在有另一个老家伙在去世前基本上在恶作剧世界，但其规模涉及成千上万的人，他们对这个家伙策划了多年的一项计划感到兴奋并热议。斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）来解释。
In 1926, in Toronto, Canada, a 72-year-old lawyer named Charles Vance Miller was at lunch at the Queens Hotel with two lawyer friends. They got into an argument over some legal matter. Miller told them they were both wrong, and he'd prove it if they followed him up to his office. He eagerly ran up three flights of stairs, grabbed a law book, plopped it on his desk, and then died. Just put his head down on the desk, and was gone.
1926年，在加拿大多伦多，一位72岁名叫查尔斯·范斯·米勒的律师在皇后酒店与两位律师朋友共进午餐。他们就某个法律问题发生了争论。米勒告诉他们都错了，并说如果他们跟着他去办公室，他会证明给他们看。他急切地爬上三层楼，抓起一本法律书，扔在桌子上，然后就死了。就这样头朝下趴在桌子上，人就没了。
A couple days later, rumors started swirling. Charles Vance Miller had done well for himself, gotten rich. He'd avoided scandal his whole life, was an upstanding citizen, though he had no family, never married. He'd hinted that he'd leave his fortune to the University of Toronto. But when his fellow lawyers brought out his will, that's not what they found. As soon as Miller's people started executing his will, they realized that his will was like an elaborate prank, as if he'd thrown a bunch of money out of a window to watch what would happen.
几天后，传言开始流传。查尔斯·范斯·米勒很有钱。他一生都在规避丑闻，是一名正直的公民，尽管他没有家庭，从未结婚。他曾暗示会把财产留给多伦多大学。但当他的同行律师拿出他的遗嘱时，他们发现的并非如此。当米勒的人开始执行他的遗嘱时，他们意识到他的遗嘱就像一场精心策划的恶作剧，好像他把一大笔钱从窗户扔出去，就为了看会发生什么。
He left stock in a brewery to prohibitionist pastors. He gave his racing stock to people who didn't believe in betting. He said he wanted to leave his vacation home in Jamaica to three other lawyers, a nice thing for them to share, except for the fact that the three lawyers all hated each other. But by far, the clause that unleashed the most mayhem was the last one. It's about all the rest of his money. I'll just read it to you.
他把酿酒厂的股票留给了禁酒主义牧师。他把赛马股票给了那些不相信赌博的人。他说他想把在牙买加的度假屋留给其他三位律师，让他们共享，但这忽略了一个事实，即这三位律师互不相容。但远比这些更混乱的条款是最后一条。那是关于他其余的所有钱。我给你们读一下。
"At the expiration of 10 years from my death, give it and its accumulations to the mother who has, since my death, given birth in Toronto to the greatest number of children, as shown by the registrations under the Vital Statistics Act," end quote. In other words, the woman who had the most babies in the 10 years after his death would be awarded a whole lot of money-- 9 million Canadian dollars in today's money, or almost $7 million US.
“在我死后10年期满时，将这笔钱及其积累的利息，赠予在我死后，在多伦多生育子女数量最多的母亲，根据《人口统计法》下的登记为准，”引用结束。换句话说，在他死后10年内生育最多婴儿的女性将获得一大笔钱——相当于今天的900万加元，或近700万美元。
There were immediately a number of theories as to why Miller did this, but none of them were charitable. If he really wanted to support a young woman with a bundle of kids, he could have just willed all the money to her at the time of his death. But setting this up over the next 10 years created a twisted contest. Some said he was an avid supporter of birth control, so maybe setting off a baby-making storm could be a wicked way to force a conversation about it.
关于米勒为什么这么做，立即出现了许多理论，但没有一个是慈善性质的。如果他真的想支持一个带着一堆孩子的年轻母亲，他可以在他死时就直接把所有钱留给她。但在接下来的10年里设置这个规则，创造了一场扭曲的比赛。有些人说他是节育的热情支持者，所以也许引发一场生育风暴是一个扭曲的方式来强制人们对此进行讨论。
Some said he was trying to test the legal system's ability to hold up a crazy will, but that he'd really expected it would be thrown out, that the money would just automatically be donated to the University of Toronto, his Alma mater. People said that Miller had been obsessed with the idea of what people would do for money. He liked to talk about how everybody had their price. Maybe he was testing the women of Toronto to see what theirs was.
有人说他是在测试法律系统能否维持这样一份疯狂的遗嘱，但其实他预期它会被作废，钱会自动捐给他的母校多伦多大学。人们说米勒一直沉迷于人们会为钱做什么的想法。他喜欢谈论每个人都有自己的价格。也许他是在测试多伦多的女性，看看她们的价格是多少。
I don't think anybody fully knows why he did this.
我不认为有人完全知道他为什么要这么做。
This is Elizabeth Wilton. She wrote a 200-page dissertation on the contest.
这是伊丽莎白·威尔顿。她写了一篇200页关于这场竞赛的论文。
I just think he saw it as a big joke.
我只是认为他把它看作一个大玩笑。
I feel like the modern day word for it would be that he was basically a troll.
我觉得现代词汇来说，他基本上就是一个喷子（Troll）。
That would be a good word for it, yeah.
那是一个很好的形容词，是的。
He pretty much cops to it in his will. He says, "This will is necessarily uncommon and capricious, because I have no dependents or near relations, and no duty rests upon me to leave any property at my death. And what I do leave is proof of my folly in gathering and retaining more than I required in my lifetime." Apparently, Miller really liked to drop dollar bills on the sidewalk, and hide and watch people pick them up.
他在遗嘱中基本承认了。他说，“这份遗嘱必然是不寻常且反复无常的，因为我没有受抚养人或近亲属，我死后没有义务留下任何财产。我所留下的，是我一生中聚集并保留了比我实际需求更多的财富这一愚行的证明。”显然，米勒真的很喜欢把美元钞票掉在人行道上，然后藏起来看人们去捡。
When I think about the kind of person who'd plant a wallet in the street and put it on YouTube today as a commentary on human nature, yeah, I feel like I know who that guy is. For the first few years after Miller died, nothing happened. A few newspaper articles were written. Nobody took it very seriously. Some relatives went to court, arguing that the money should go to them.
当我想到今天那种会把钱包放在街上并录成YouTube视频作为对人性的评论的人时，是的，我觉得我知道那个家伙是谁。米勒死后的头几年，什么也没发生。报纸上写了几篇报道。没人太当回事。一些亲戚诉诸法院，认为钱应该归他们。
And then, six years after his death, the attorney general introduced a bill trying to nullify the will and have the money donated to the University of Toronto. This was a mistake-- totally backfired. Before this, not many people knew about the will. But now that the government was trying to invalidate it, the press picked it up, and there was a huge public outcry. But not in the way you might think. The public was like, baby-making race? Hell, yeah, we want a baby-making race.
然后，在他死后六年，司法部长提出了一项试图使遗嘱作废并将钱捐给多伦多大学的法案。这是一个错误——完全适得其反。在此之前，没多少人知道这份遗嘱。但现在政府试图使它无效，媒体进行了报道，并引发了巨大的公众抗议。但不是你想象的那种方式。公众反应是，生育比赛？太棒了，我们想要一场生育比赛。
Women's groups supported the contest because they felt women should have a fair shot at the money, which, what can I say? It was a different time. Others disagreed with the government intervening in people's wills and affairs. Altogether, it caused an uproar. The government backtracked, said, OK, fine. You people have fun. And with that, the race was on. Usually when this story has been told, it's like, ha ha. A man created this zany will that set off a wild baby-making storm in Canada.
妇女团体支持这场竞赛，因为她们觉得女性应该有公平的机会获得这笔钱，怎么说呢？那时是一个不同的时代。其他人不同意政府干预人们的遗嘱和事务。总的来说，它引起了一场轩然大波。政府退缩了，说，好吧，行。你们自己玩得开心吧。随着这样，比赛开始了。通常这个故事被讲述时，就像是，哈哈。一个男人创造了这个滑稽的遗嘱，在加拿大引发了一场疯狂的生育风暴。
It conjures Brady Bunch images of big families happily schtupping their way to fame and fortune, knee deep in Cabbage Patch children. But the way it unfolded was actually much darker, because, of course, the story is about an old man encouraging women to go through the excruciating pain and danger of childbirth as often as possible in a 10-year period-- a 10-year period that was already half over. This contest didn't really get started until six years in. That made it skewed from the start.
它让人联想到布雷迪一家那样的大家庭，快乐地通过生育孩子来换取名利，在孩子堆里打滚。但它的展开方式其实要黑暗得多，因为显然，这个故事讲述的是一个老人鼓励女性在10年内尽可能频繁地经历极其痛苦和危险的分娩——一个已经过去了一半的10年。这场比赛直到第六年才真正开始。这从一开始就是扭曲的。
It meant suddenly the only contenders were women who had about six babies in the last six years, women who didn't even know there was a contest to be part of. They found out about it quick, when reporters started pounding on their doors.
这意味着突然间唯一的竞争者是那些在过去六年里生了大约六个孩子的女性，她们甚至不知道还有这样一场比赛。当记者开始疯狂敲门时，她们很快就知道了。
It was madness, really. It was a media feeding frenzy.
这简直是疯狂。这是一种媒体的盛宴。
This is Karyn Nolan. She worked with Elizabeth to develop a screenplay for a movie based on the contest that aired on Canadian television in 2002. As soon as the will was verified, reporters went through the birth registry, found women who had already given birth to about six children since Charles's death, and dashed to their homes to try and get the exclusive.
这是卡琳·诺兰。她曾与伊丽莎白合作开发了一部基于这场竞赛的电影剧本，该电影于2002年在加拿大电视台播出。遗嘱一经核实，记者们就翻阅了出生登记册，找到了那些在查尔斯死后已经生了约六个孩子的女性，并冲向她们的家，试图获得独家新闻。
You know they coined the phrase, the Stork Derby, comparing it to like a horse race. So there was a mad dash to track down the women, get their exclusive stories, and to follow them and hound them on the very intimate and personal details of their life.
你知道他们创造了一个短语，“鹳鸟德比”（Stork Derby），将其比作赛马。所以有一场疯狂的冲刺去追踪这些女性，获取她们的独家故事，并跟踪和骚扰她们生活中非常私密和个人的细节。
It must have been a jarring experience to be an automatic front-runner in this bizarre contest. But most of the mothers went along with it because of the 9 million dollars. Many of the contestants were desperately poor. During those first six years, the Great Depression had taken hold. Nearly a quarter of Toronto's families were on welfare. Families were living in shacks or camps. Some even ate groundhogs to keep from starving. Canada's birth rate had actually plummeted at the time.
作为一个在这个离奇竞赛中自动领跑的人，那一定是一种令人不安的经历。但大多数母亲因为那900万美元而顺从了。许多参赛者在极度贫困中挣扎。在那前六年里，大萧条已经到来。多伦多近四分之一的家庭依靠救济金生活。家庭住在棚屋或营地里。有些人甚至吃土拨鼠来维持生存。当时加拿大的出生率实际上已经暴跌。
And so most of the families that suddenly found themselves in the running to receive this Stork Derby money agreed to media scrutiny because they wanted the chance at the prize, and because, in the short term, the newspapers offered them money-- exclusive contracts where reporters could come and photograph and interview the families whenever they wanted to. Sometimes the families even got advertising deals for things like soap.
所以大多数突然发现自己有资格获得“鹳鸟德比”奖金的家庭都同意接受媒体的监督，因为他们想要获得奖金的机会，而且因为，在短期内，报纸为他们提供了一些钱——独家合同，记者可以随时随地来拍照和采访这些家庭。有时家庭甚至还能获得肥皂之类产品的广告合同。
In many ways, this was sort of like an OG reality show, albeit a really perverse one. The front-runners of the Stork Derby even became household names, like Jon & Kate Plus 8, or maybe more like Octomom. After all, it was billed on the newsreels as freak Canadian race. Papers all over the world, from the New York Daily News to the Marshfield, Wisconsin, News Herald picked up the story.
在许多方面，这就像是一个原始的真人秀，尽管是一个非常变态的真人秀。鹳鸟德比的领跑者甚至成了家喻户晓的名字，就像《乔恩和凯特+8》，或者可能更像《八胞胎妈妈》（Octomom）。毕竟，它在新闻片中被称为“加拿大疯狂种族竞赛”。世界各地的报纸，从《纽约每日新闻》到马什菲尔德的《威斯康星新闻先驱报》都报道了这个故事。
The press followed a bunch of contenders, but I'm only going to run through three of the long-term favorites to win. One of the first competitors that the newspapers dug up was Mrs. Grace Bagnato. I don't want to give away who won or how many kids Mrs. Bagnato actually had during the race, but over her lifetime, Mrs. Bagnato was pregnant 24 times, though only 12 of those children lived.
媒体跟踪了一堆竞争者，但我只打算讲其中三个长期有望获胜的选手。报纸挖掘出的第一批参赛者之一是格蕾丝·巴尼亚托（Grace Bagnato）夫人。我不想剧透获胜者是谁或者巴尼亚托夫人在比赛期间实际上生了多少个孩子，但她一生中怀孕了24次，尽管只有12个孩子活了下来。
She was a working mother. She was a whiz with languages-- picked up Polish, German, Yiddish, and worked as a court interpreter in Italian. All the while, she raised her 12 children and would get up at 4:30 in the morning to make two dozen butter tarts, macaroni, meatballs, sausage, and her famous red sauce for her family. But the public didn't exactly see her as a hero. Here's Karyn again.
她是一位职业母亲。她非常有语言天赋——学会了波兰语、德语、意第绪语，并担任过意大利语的法庭翻译。与此同时，她抚养了她的12个孩子，每天早上4:30起床，为家人做两打黄油馅饼、通心粉、肉丸、香肠和她著名的红酱。但公众并不完全把她视为英雄。这是卡琳再次发言。
The cultural makeup of Toronto at the time was a very WASPy, WASPy society. And we have this Italian family here who is reproducing children at a rate that outpaced the white, Protestant Anglo-Saxons.
当时多伦多的文化构成是一个非常盎格鲁-撒克逊（WASP）的社会。而我们这里有一个意大利家庭，他们生育孩子的速度超过了白人、新教徒、盎格鲁-撒克逊人。
Mrs. Bagnato's husband was an Italian immigrant, and some papers weren't kind about that. These were the years leading up to World War II. Of course, it didn't help that one of the other Italian contestants named one of their Derby babies little Benito Mussolini. But because of their nationality, Italian families in the race received phone calls calling their families fascists and threatening to kidnap their children.
巴尼亚托夫人的丈夫是意大利移民，一些报纸对此并不友善。那是通向第二次世界大战的几年。当然，另一位意大利参赛者把他们的德比宝宝起名为“小贝尼托·墨索里尼”也没帮上忙。但由于他们的国籍，参赛的意大利家庭收到了电话，称他们的家庭为法西斯，并威胁要绑架他们的孩子。
Contestant number two was Mrs. X. She was the scandalous one.
二号选手是X夫人。她是丑闻缠身的那位。
She was a social outcast because her children were fathered by different men, which was taboo, and she was shamed for that. She was considered to be a trollop by having children with more than one man.
她是一个社会弃儿，因为她的孩子是与不同男人所生，这在当时是禁忌，她因此受到羞辱。她因为与不止一个男人有孩子而被视为一个淫妇。
That's a saucy word.
这是一个粗俗的词。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I should start using that.
我应该开始用它了。
Mrs. X had five children from her husband, but then her marriage fell apart. He moved out, and she entered into a new relationship with a man and had another five kids with him. She wanted to marry him, but didn't have enough money to go through with her divorce. All in all, Mrs. X had 10 children by the time she was 24. She tried to hide her identity because of the circumstances of her situation, but her name was eventually revealed-- Pauline Mae Clark.
X夫人与丈夫育有五个孩子，但随后婚姻破裂。他搬走了，她开始了一段新的关系，并与那个男人又生了五个孩子。她想嫁给他，但没有足够的钱去离婚。总而言之，X夫人在24岁时就有10个孩子。由于她的处境，她试图隐藏身份，但她的名字最终还是被揭露了——波琳·梅·克拉克（Pauline Mae Clark）。
Contestant number three was Mrs. Kenny.
三号选手是肯尼夫人（Mrs. Kenny）。
She's my favorite character in the whole story.
她是整个故事中我最喜欢的角色。
Why is she your favorite?
为什么她是你的最爱？
I think her eccentricity, for one thing, her passion, and her undeniable belief that she was the chosen one, if you will.
我认为是她的古怪，一方面，她的激情，以及她不可动摇的信念，即她是天选之子，如果你愿意的话。
Mrs. Kenny was in it to win it. She was under 5 feet tall, but over the course of her lifetime, she wound up carrying 19 pregnancies to term. She was French Canadian, married to an Irish man, and she believed that money was hers. She said she had the gift of second sight, and a divine connection with Miller, who told her she was going to win. So of course, it had to be true.
肯尼夫人一心想赢。她身高不到5英尺，但一生中最终足月怀胎19次。她是法裔加拿大人，嫁给了一个爱尔兰男人，她坚信那笔钱是她的。她说她有“预知”的天赋，并与米勒有神圣的联系，米勒告诉她她会赢。所以当然，这一定是真的。
Mrs. Kenny was a talented wood carver, and often sold her carvings in the street. And she carved a large number of statues of Miller, even named one of her children after him. At one point, a bunch of the leading Derby mothers got together and said, screw this whole race. Let's just share the winnings. It was a ton of money. They were all poor. It would still result in plenty for everyone. But Mrs. Kenny was the sole holdout, the only one who insisted no.
肯尼夫人是一位才华横溢的木雕师，经常在街上出售她的木雕。她雕刻了大量的米勒雕像，甚至以他的名字给其中一个孩子命名。有一次，一群领跑的德比母亲聚在一起说，去他妈的比赛。咱们平分奖金吧。那是一大笔钱。她们都很穷。每个人依然能分到很多。但肯尼夫人是唯一的反对者，她是唯一坚持说“不”的人。
I'm the winner, she shouted once, and I won't split with anybody. Why should I? It's my money. And if the judge doesn't give it all to me, I'll walk right up to the bench and punch him in the eye. So yeah, Mrs. Kenny was tough as nails, but she probably was the poorest of the three. Her family lived in a slum, and their home was infested with rats. One night, rats attacked three of her children. Tiny, three-month-old Patrick had the worst of it. Here's Karyn.
“我是赢家，”她曾大喊道，“我不会和任何人分。为什么我要分？这是我的钱。如果法官不把钱全部给我，我就直接走到法官席上往他眼睛上打一拳。”所以是的，肯尼夫人坚如磐石，但她可能是三人中最穷的。她的家庭住在贫民窟，房子里老鼠泛滥。一天晚上，老鼠袭击了她的三个孩子。3个月大的小帕特里克伤得最重。这是卡琳的描述。
So yes, it had bitten the baby in the face and neck area. And as we all know, throughout history, rats carry diseases. But they couldn't afford the hospital. They couldn't. This is so difficult to even talk-- it's unbelievable that it still chokes me up.
所以是的，它咬了婴儿的脸和脖子区域。众所周知，纵观历史，老鼠会携带疾病。但他们负担不起医院的费用。他们负担不起。这很难说出口——真是难以置信，想到这里我还是会哽咽。
Mrs. Kenny and her neighbors tried desperately to have the public health nurse visit her home, but to no avail. The baby died.
肯尼夫人和她的邻居拼命想让公共卫生护士访问她的家，但无济于事。婴儿死了。
And then it was all over the front pages of the newspaper, but always written in terms of what this meant for the chances of Mrs. Kenny or whatever other woman that the coverage was centered on. Every loss, or tragedy, or triumph was always put in terms of their chances in the race, not in terms of what kind of a system do we have where someone's baby can die of rat bites in the first place?
然后这件事登上了报纸头版，但总是从这件事对肯尼夫人或报道所关注的其他女性的获胜机会意味着什么的角度来写的。每一次损失、悲剧或胜利，总是被归结为她们在比赛中的机会，而不是归结为：我们到底处于一个什么样的系统中，才导致一个人的婴儿竟然会死于老鼠叮咬？
It's hard to say how many women had babies specifically for this race. When they talked to reporters, everyone always said the same thing. I would have had this child anyway. I tend to believe Mrs. Bagnato, and many of the other Catholic families in the race. I don't think Mrs. Bagnato was ever playing the game. She'd been cranking out a baby a year long before she heard a word about the Derby, so the whole contest was just an added bonus to her.
很难说有多少女性是因为这场比赛而生孩子的。当她们和记者交谈时，每个人都说了同样的话。我反正也会生这个孩子的。我倾向于相信巴尼亚托夫人，以及比赛中的许多其他天主教家庭。我不认为巴尼亚托夫人是在玩这个游戏。在她听到关于德比的消息之前，她早就每年生一个孩子了，所以整个比赛对她来说只是一个额外的奖励。
But then there was Mrs. Kenny, who was obviously playing to win, and said outright that she was trying to make babies. And then you have Mrs. Clark. Mrs. Clark's situation was the most unsettling. It came out that Mrs. Clark's lover had drawn up a contract with her where he could get half her winnings if he impregnated her enough. Mrs. Clark's lover was also abusive. He'd given her a black eye, broke her door down, chased her out into the street after a fight.
但后来有肯尼夫人，她显然是为赢而玩的，并直言不讳地说她在努力生孩子。然后你有克拉克夫人。克拉克夫人的处境最令人不安。事实证明，克拉克夫人的情人与她签订了一份合同，如果他让她生足够的孩子，他就可以得到她的一半奖金。克拉克夫人的情人还家暴。他在争吵后给了她一个黑眼圈，撞坏了她的门，把她赶到了街上。
So maybe she didn't want to be pregnant as many times as she was. Maybe she was forced to. Here's Elizabeth.
所以也许她并不想怀孕那么多次。也许她是被迫的。这是伊丽莎白的观点。
You sort of wonder, was she basically abused? Was she taken advantage of? Because if you think about also the kind of power dynamic that Miller set up between men and women-- and at that time, if your partner, or if your husband, or your lover thought that if he got you pregnant over and over, that you might win millions of dollars-- and she was a very young woman. And--
你有点怀疑，她基本上是被虐待了吗？她是被利用了吗？因为如果你也想到米勒在男女之间设置的那种权力动态——而在那个时候，如果你的伴侣，或者你的丈夫，或者你的情人认为如果你让你一次又一次地怀孕，你可能会赢得数百万美元——而她是一个非常年轻的女性。并且——
So you were sort of insinuating that maybe these women might have been coerced.
所以你是在暗示也许这些女性可能受到了胁迫。
I mean, I don't know. I think it doesn't take a lot for someone to put together with this young woman, and so many babies, and with this huge prize.
我的意思是，我不知道。我认为一个人联想到这个年轻女性，这么多孩子，还有这笔巨额奖金，并不需要太多的联想。
In 1933. It looked like Mrs. Bagnato was going to win. Then in 1934, headlines read that Mrs. Kenny had taken the lead. In 1935, another woman, Mrs. Timleck, quote, "sped to the front." In 1936, Madam X was listed as a late entry, tied for second. All the while, the physical toll for these mothers was enormous. Mrs. Bagnato suffered a hemorrhage near the end of her final pregnancy, and many of the Stork Derby mothers were in and out of the hospital for operations and transfusions.
1933年，看起来巴尼亚托夫人要赢了。然后1934年，头条新闻读到肯尼夫人领先。1935年，另一位女性，蒂姆莱克夫人（Mrs. Timleck），引用，“疾驰到前列”。1936年，X夫人被列为后期参赛者，并列第二。与此同时，这些母亲的身体损耗是巨大的。巴尼亚托夫人在最后一次怀孕快结束时出血，许多鹳鸟德比的母亲为了手术和输血进出医院。
And all three mothers suffered the emotional toll of having stillborn babies during the race. Most of the women couldn't afford to have their children in hospitals, and so the infant mortality rate of the Derby babies was six times that of the national average. 34% of these babies died. But aside from an article or two, again, the press only saw these deaths in the context of the race.
三位母亲都在比赛中经历了死胎的痛苦。大多数女性负担不起在医院生孩子，所以德比宝宝的婴儿死亡率是全国平均水平的六倍。34%的这些婴儿死亡。但除了偶尔的一两篇文章，同样，新闻界只在比赛的背景下看待这些死亡。
The headline in a 1936 Montreal paper was, "Stillborn Infant May Assure Prize." Underneath, "A stillborn child may assure Mrs. Matthew Kenny the prize in the Stork Derby under the will of late Charles Vance Miller. Her nearest competitor is believed to be Mrs. Joseph Bagnato."
1936年蒙特利尔报纸的头条是，《死婴可能确保奖金》。标题下方写着，“根据已故查尔斯·范斯·米勒的遗嘱，一个死胎婴儿可能确保马修·肯尼夫人获得鹳鸟德比的奖金。她最接近的竞争对手被认为是约瑟夫·巴尼亚托夫人。”
The race ended on Halloween 1936. But at first, it wasn't clear who had won. Here's how our three competitors stood on that date. Mrs. Kenny claimed to have had 11 children. Mrs. Clark said she had 11, as well. Mrs. Bagnato had nine. But Mrs. Kenny and Mrs. Clark didn't walk away with the prize that easily. With Mrs. Clark, the scandalous one who had tied for the largest number of children, the lawyers in charge of the estate had some questions about her case, and raised the question of whether children born out of wedlock should count.
比赛在1936年万圣节结束。但起初，还不清楚谁赢了。这是我们三位竞争者在那天的名次。肯尼夫人声称有11个孩子。克拉克夫人说她也有11个。巴尼亚托夫人有9个。但肯尼夫人和克拉克夫人并没有那么容易带走奖金。对于并列拥有最多孩子的丑闻人物克拉克夫人，负责遗产的律师对她的情况有一些疑问，并提出了婚外生子是否应该计算的问题。
This is where it was clear that there had been a huge oversight. Nobody had actually set rules for this contest at its beginning. Remember, Miller explained this whole contest in two sentences in his will. So as the court saw it, there were nuances that needed to be figured out, rules to be set. But of course, only after the fact of everything, after the babies had been born and the blood transfusions administered.
就在这里很清楚，在比赛开始时有一个巨大的疏忽。没有人为这场比赛设定规则。记住，米勒在遗嘱中只用了两句话来解释整个竞赛。所以法院看来，有一些细微差别需要理清，规则需要设定。但这当然是在事后，在婴儿已经出生、输血已经完成之后。
A massive, multi-way court battle broke out. All of the contestants had to go to court to prove that they had the most children. Each woman had to lawyer up and go up against the lawyers for the executors of the estate. The fight went on for two years. And of course, now the rules would be determined in front of an audience.
一场大规模的多方法院诉讼爆发了。所有的参赛者都必须上法庭证明她们拥有最多的孩子。每位女性都必须请律师，并与遗产执行人的律师抗衡。这场斗争持续了两年。当然，现在规则将在观众面前决定。
To figure out if her illegitimate children would count, Mrs. Clark and her lover's abusive sexual history was scrutinized on the stand. He recounted his physical violence with her, admitted to giving her a black eye and busting down the door to her house, and to the contract he drew up. When he mentioned the contract, the courtroom burst out into raucous, mocking laughter. And in fact, the lawyers regularly threw in crude jokes during the trial, soliciting giggles from the audience.
为了弄清楚她的非婚生子女是否算数，克拉克夫人和她情人的虐待性性史在法庭上受到了严审。他叙述了他对她的暴力行为，承认给了她一个黑眼圈并砸坏了她家的门，还承认了他们签署的合同。当他提到合同时，法庭爆发出刺耳的、嘲弄的笑声。事实上，律师们在庭审中经常插播粗俗的笑话，引诱观众窃笑。
In the end, it was decided that illegitimate children could not be counted within the Derby, and so Mrs. Clark's number got knocked down to five. She was out of the running.
最后，决定非婚生子女不能计入德比，因此克拉克夫人的数字被扣减到五个。她被淘汰出局。
Then came Mrs. Kenny, the one who believed she was the winner and had carved statues of Miller. She'd also tied for 11, but apparently two of her children had not been properly registered, probably because Mrs. Kenny was too poor to deliver her children in hospitals. She'd had them at home instead. That brought her count down to nine children, but no big deal. She was still in the running. Then the lawyers pointed out three of her children had been stillborn.
接着是肯尼夫人，那个认为自己是赢家并雕刻了米勒雕像的女人。她也并列11个，但显然她的两个孩子没有被妥善登记，可能是因为肯尼夫人太穷了，负担不起在医院分娩。她在家生了他们。这使她的统计数降到九个孩子，但这没什么大不了。她仍在竞争中。然后律师指出她的三个孩子是死胎。
Quick warning-- I'm about to talk about a lot of traumatic births. Until this point, everyone had assumed that stillborn children would count for the Derby. Again, this hadn't been in the rules. And after all, these women had carried these children to term. But now in Mrs. Kenney's trial, lawyers for the executors of the estate started questioning that. And so Mrs. Kennedy had to sit while a pack of lawyers argued around her about how legitimate her dead children were.
快速警告——我要谈论很多创伤性分娩。到目前为止，每个人都假设死胎应该计入德比。同样，这并没有在规则里。毕竟，这些女性确实足月怀胎了。但现在在肯尼夫人的审判中，遗产执行人的律师开始质疑这一点。于是肯尼夫人不得不坐在一群律师围绕着她争论她的死婴有多“合法”。
They brought up doctors and had them give graphic descriptions of the stillbirths, if each baby breathed, if its heart ever beat. She had to relive the moments all over again. Mrs. Kenny cried throughout this, and eventually ran from the courtroom.
他们找来了医生，让他们对死产进行了生动的描述，描述婴儿是否呼吸过，心脏是否跳动过。她不得不一遍又一遍地重温那些时刻。肯尼夫人整场审判都在哭泣，并最终从法庭跑了出去。
It was just all too much for her. And at one point, she left the courtroom just screaming that she was being treated like a dog. And there never was a sensitive portrait of this woman. It was all sort of caricature-style, so I think the coverage just continued in that way, you know?
这对于她来说实在太多了。在某一时刻，她尖叫着跑出法庭，说她像狗一样被对待。而且从来没有任何关于这个女人的敏感刻画。它都是那种讽刺风格，所以我认为报道只是以那种方式继续，你知道吗？
The newspaper report said she was shrieking, insinuated that she was drunk, and said, quote, "During the scuffle, Mrs. Kenny dealt at least half a dozen hard blows on the arms and bodies of the officers who showed great restraint in their tactics." In the end, it didn't help her case. "A child born dead is not, in truth, a child," the judge wrote. "It was that which might have been a child." Her count was knocked down to six. Mrs. Kenny was out of the running.
报纸报道说她在尖叫，暗示她喝醉了，并写道，引用，“在混乱中，肯尼夫人向那些在战术上表现出极大克制的警官的手臂和身体上猛击了至少半打重拳。”最后，这并没有帮到她的案子。“一个出生时已死的人，实际上不是一个孩子，”法官写道。“那只是本可能成为孩子的东西。”她的计数值被扣减到六个。肯尼夫人被淘汰出局。
Lastly, there was Mrs. Bagnato, who, again, had nine children. But one was stillborn and another was unregistered. Mrs. Bagnato suggested that there was some conspiracy with this. She said she'd registered the child herself at the Parliament Buildings. She was quoted as saying, "If they can't find the record, it'll be just too bad for them up there. I will tear the Parliament Buildings apart before I give up. I'm supposed to be in the hospital now with another baby coming, but I'll stay on my feet until I drop or this is cleared up."
最后，是巴尼亚托夫人，她同样有九个孩子。但有一个死胎，另一个未登记。巴尼亚托夫人暗示这其中存在某种阴谋。她说她自己在议会大厦登记了那个孩子。她被引用说，“如果他们找不到记录，那是他们上面的错。在放弃之前，我会把议会大厦拆了。我现在应该在医院里等着另一个孩子出生，但我会一直站着直到我倒下或者这件事被澄清。”
But her protestations didn't sway the judge, and she eventually did give up. After all, she did have a job, and almost a dozen mouths to feed.
但她的抗议并没有动摇法官，她最终还是放弃了。毕竟，她确实有一份工作，还有近一打嘴要喂。
At the end of two years, none of the three favorites wound up at the finish line. Four other women, with nine babies each, won. Each of these women walked away with what today would be about 2 million Canadian dollars, or $1 and 1/2 million US dollars. Most were latecomers who really only became candidates when the heavy hitters were eliminated. And these four women had something else in common. Here's Elizabeth.
两年后，三位热门选手都没有到达终点线。另外四位各有九个孩子的女性赢了。这些女性每人都带着今天价值约200万加元，或150万美元的奖金离开。大多数是后期才赶上来的，只有在热门人选被淘汰时才成为候选人。而这四位女性还有另一个共同点。这是伊丽莎白的观点。
I mean, the families that won were white, Protestant families who were essentially middle class, and who had homes that, when the reporters went into them and described the homes, it was always the clean and tidy home, and the well-kept this. And the forerunners through the whole race were working-class people, and unemployed people, and they had varied ethnic backgrounds.
我的意思是，获胜的家庭都是白人、新教徒家庭，他们基本上是中产阶级，而且他们拥有当记者进入并描述他们的家时，总是被描述为整洁干净、维护良好的房子。而在整个比赛中一直领跑的则是工人阶级、失业人员，以及有不同民族背景的人。
Maybe it wasn't a coincidence that these women didn't win. Maybe they didn't win because they didn't have the means to navigate the system as elegantly. Or maybe the judge who decided the contest had his finger on the scale. In its last four years, the public's view of the contest had turned, as people saw how it played out. It had encouraged the poorest women to have the most children.
也许这些女性没赢不是巧合。也许她们没赢是因为她们没有优雅地驾驭系统的手段。或者也许决定比赛的法官在天平上动了手脚。在最后四年里，公众对这场比赛的看法已经转变，因为人们看到了它是如何发展的。它鼓励了最贫困的女性生育最多的孩子。
That set alarm bells off for a big group of people in what was a growing and popular movement at the time-- eugenics. Teddy Roosevelt was into eugenics. Alexander Graham Bell, WEB Dubois, even Helen Keller. A refresher-- eugenicists believed that in order to improve the human species, some people shouldn't be allowed to reproduce. And yes, that's just as creepy as it sounds.
这在那时一个正在增长且流行的运动中为一大群人敲响了警钟——优生学。西奥多·罗斯福是优生学的拥护者。亚历山大·格拉汉姆·贝尔、W.E.B. 杜波依斯，甚至海伦·凯勒。复习一下——优生学家认为，为了改善人类物种，有些人不应该被允许繁殖。是的，这和听起来一样令人毛骨悚然。
At the end of the contest, they came forth in droves to say that the money shouldn't be given to any women. Here's Elizabeth.
在比赛结束时，他们成群结队地出来说，钱不应该给任何女性。这是伊丽莎白的描述。
The social commentary was around, who are these people, and should they be reproducing? They're not Canadian-born. They're poor. They're not the right people.
当时的社会评论围绕着，“这些人是谁，他们应该繁殖吗？”“他们不是加拿大出生的。他们很穷。他们不是合适的人选。”
A minister, Reverend Claire Sillcox, submitted written testimony against the participants as, quote, "unspeakable women," and argued that these poor children would eventually reduce wages and lower the standard of living. An editor for a Canadian newspaper said that the contest attracted, quote, "those whose progeny would be of little use to the state." Elizabeth and Karyn believe that this environment influenced the judge, that he eliminated, on technicalities, all the contestants who had not made the right kinds of babies. Here's Karyn.
一位部长，克莱尔·希尔考克斯（Claire Sillcox）牧师，提交了反对参赛者的书面证词，称她们为“不可言说的女性”，并认为这些贫困的孩子最终会降低工资并降低生活水平。一位加拿大报纸的编辑说，这场比赛吸引了，引用，“那些后代对国家没什么用处的人。”伊丽莎白和卡琳相信这种环境影响了法官，他以技术理由淘汰了所有没有生出“正确”品种孩子的参赛者。这是卡琳的观点。
Yeah. I do believe that it was intentional, because they went to such lengths to discredit those that were the others-- the French Canadian Catholic, the woman with the illegitimate children, the Italian Catholic with her immigrant husband. It became a platform for them to send the message of, to use of a modern phrase, stay in your lane, like immigrants know their place. They were definitely trying to send a message.
是的。我相信这是故意的，因为他们不遗余力地诋毁那些“其他人”——法裔加拿大天主教徒、非婚生子女的女性、拥有移民丈夫的意大利天主教徒。它成为了他们传递信息的平台，用现代短语来说，就是“安分守己”，就像移民要明白自己的位置一样。他们绝对是在试图传递一个信息。
After the lawsuit took place, Mrs. Clark and Mrs. Kenny both filed appeals, and both received settlements for the equivalent of 200,000 Canadian dollars each. Mrs. Bagnato, the immigrant translator, walked away with nothing.
诉讼发生后，克拉克夫人和肯尼夫人均提出了上诉，并各自获得了相当于20万加元的和解金。作为移民翻译的巴尼亚托夫人最终一无所有。
Ladies and gentlemen, the antipasto bar is now open.
各位女士们先生们，开胃菜吧台现在开放了。
Last December, I shuffled around a table piled high with prosciutto and provolone. Santa came into the banquet hall, and little kids ran past me to get their gifts from him. I was at the 89th annual Bagnato holiday party, which, as you can imagine, is bigger than most holiday family gatherings. Mrs. Bagnato, remember, had 12 children, and they had children, who also had children, who by now have had children, too.
去年12月，我绕着一张堆满意大利熏火腿和波萝伏洛干酪的桌子走了走。圣诞老人来到了宴会厅，小孩们跑过我身边去拿他们的礼物。我在参加第89届年度巴尼亚托节日派对，你可以想象，这比大多数节日家庭聚会要大得多。记住，巴尼亚托夫人有12个孩子，他们有了孩子，那些孩子也有了孩子，现在也有了孩子。
One of her great-granddaughters gives me a rough estimate. There are over 150 people now who are direct descendants of Grace. About 110 of the descendants and their families are in a reception hall giving generous air kisses, then turning, screaming, oh my god, Uncle Paulie.
她的一位曾孙女给了我一个粗略的估计。现在有超过150人是格蕾丝的直系后代。大约110名后代及其家属在接待大厅里慷慨地进行空中飞吻，然后转身尖叫，“噢天哪，保利叔叔。”
Everybody kissy-kissy everybody.
每个人都在亲吻每个人。
Among the attendees? Many teachers, an agent for the cast of the Young and the Restless, a few writers, and a former mayor. So take that, eugenicists. But talking to a bunch of the Bagnatos, not that many of them know much about the Derby. And those who do, don't seem to care.
参加者中有谁？许多老师、《年轻和躁动》演员的经纪人、几位作家和一位前市长。所以，优生学家们看着吧。但和一些巴尼亚托家族的人交谈，没几个人知道多少关于德比的事。而知道的人，似乎也不在意。
Does it make you mad that Grace didn't get any money?
格蕾丝没拿到钱让你生气吗？
No. Life's not all about money. But no, I don't think so. From what I hear, she was just that amazing woman with a huge heart. And I don't think she would get angry. Her oldest daughter, Mildred, told me a story that might answer that question. You know, her mother made a huge pot of sauce on the stove for Sunday dinner. And she had asked Mildred and one of the boys to put it out on the back porch to cool off. And when they went out to get it, it was gone. And Mildred was very angry. And her mother said, but just think, Mildred, somebody's having such a wonderful dinner tonight.
不。生活不全是关于钱。不，我不这么认为。据我所知，她就是那个拥有一颗巨大心脏的神奇女性。我不认为她会生气。她最大的女儿米尔德里德（Mildred）告诉我一个故事，也许能回答那个问题。你知道，她母亲为周日的晚餐在炉子上做了一大锅酱汁。她让米尔德里德和其中一个男孩把它放在后门廊里冷却。当他们出去拿它时，它不见了。米尔德里德非常生气。但她母亲说，“但是想想吧，米尔德里德，今天晚上有人吃到了多么美妙的晚餐啊。”
After the Derby, Grace told the whole family that they weren't ever to talk about that dumb contest ever again, but she otherwise seemed unfazed. She continued having more kids, even took in an orphan from off the street. It's true that the chaos of the Stork Derby turned her into a laughingstock, and rocked Toronto for over a decade. But a century later, it's mostly forgotten-- just a funny old tale from a hundred years ago.
德比结束后，格蕾丝告诉全家人他们再也不准谈论那个愚蠢的比赛了，但她本人似乎并没有受到影响。她继续生了更多的孩子，甚至从街上领养了一个孤儿。虽然鹳鸟德比的混乱确实使她成了笑柄，并在十多年里震惊了多伦多。但一个世纪后，它大多已被遗忘——只是百年前一个有趣的旧故事。
Charles Vance Miller didn't have any children, and unless you preface it with, remember that crazy Stork Derby guy, nobody remembers his name. But more than a hundred people get together every year to share stories about Grace Bagnato. There's more than one way to leave a legacy.
查尔斯·范斯·米勒没有孩子，除非你在名字前加上“记住那个疯狂的鹳鸟德比家伙”，否则没人记得他的名字。但每年有超过100人聚在一起分享关于格蕾丝·巴尼亚托的故事。留下遗产的方式不止一种。
Stephanie Foo. She used to be one of our producers here at our show. She's now off writing a book that is part memoir, part science about complex PTSD, and looking for a publisher. Coming up, something said in the middle of a race between one racer and another that eats at both of them for years after. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·傅。她曾是我们节目的制作人之一。她现在正在写一本书，这是一部关于复杂性创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的半回忆录、半科学书籍，正在寻找出版商。接下来，一场比赛中一位赛车手和另一位之间说的话，在多年后依然啃噬着他们两人。那是芝加哥公共广播电台将在我们节目继续时讲的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program--
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——
[FUSE BURNING]
[导火索燃烧]
--"The Long Fuse."
——《长导火索》。
[EXPLOSION]
[爆炸]
[LAUGHS] We never really use sound effects on our show, and that was totally worth it. Anyway, today's show, "The Long Fuse," is about people saying things that end up having consequences for years after. We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Meatball and Chain. This last story is about three little words, uttered at 25 miles an hour during a sporting event, and the years and years of feelings that those words unleashed. Jared Marcelle tells what happened.
[笑声] 我们节目从不使用音效，那一次绝对值得。总之，今天的节目《长导火索》，讲述的是人们说出的话最终在多年后产生后果的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，肉丸和锁链。最后一个故事关于三个短词，在体育赛事中以每小时25英里的速度说出，并由此引发了多年来的感受。杰瑞德·马塞尔（Jared Marcelle）讲述了发生了什么。
Ian Dille was 21 when this whole thing happened. He was competing in a big bike race, a national championship. It was in Gainesville. Ian's from Austin. And when they got there, he saw that the roads were pretty flat, just like home. Plus, it was humid, but not too bad, just like home. So he was like, hey, I have a good shot at this thing. When the race starts, everyone comes out blazing.
伊恩·迪尔（Ian Dille）发生这一切时21岁。他正在参加一场大型自行车比赛，全国锦标赛。是在盖恩斯维尔。伊恩来自奥斯汀。当他们到达那里时，他发现道路相当平坦，就像家里一样。另外，天气潮湿，但还不错，就像家里一样。所以他心想，嘿，我有很好的机会赢。比赛开始时，每个人都火力全开。
Everybody was racing really aggressively in that race. There was just a lot of attacks. There'd be a lead group of five riders, and then it would become 10, and then 15, and 20. And then a group would come out of that five riders. And it was kind of like this amoeba that kept breaking up and coming back together.
每个人在那场比赛中都竞争得非常积极。攻击很多。先是一个由五名车手组成的领先小组，然后变成了10名，然后是15名，20名。然后一个小组从那五名车手中脱颖而出。它就像是一个不断分裂又重组的变形虫。
Ian wasn't considered one of the favorites, but on this day in this race, he was better than most. He kept attacking, taking the lead, staying near the front the whole time. And then at one point, he realizes, oh man, I'm first. Now you'd think being in first place is a good thing. But for the majority of a bike race, competitors play hot potato with the top spot. Chances are, if you stay in first early on for too long, you're probably going to lose.
伊恩并不被认为是热门选手之一，但在这一天的比赛中，他比大多数人都强。他不断进攻，取得领先，全程保持在前列。然后他意识到，噢天哪，我是第一。现在你可能会认为第一名是一件好事。但在自行车比赛的大部分时间里，竞争者们对领先位置玩着“热土豆”游戏。很有可能，如果你在早期保持第一名太久，你很可能会输。
No, you're definitely going to lose, because the person in first takes on all the wind. In cycling, this is a big thing. The front-runner basically works the hardest.
不，你肯定会输，因为第一名要承担所有的风阻。在自行车运动中，这是一件大事。领跑者基本上是最辛苦的。
And that makes the person that's pedaling behind them have to work a lot less hard. I mean scientifically, it's like 30% to 50% less hard.
而这使得跟在他们后面踩踏板的人不必那么费力。在科学上，这大约是少费30%到50%的力。
That's why in bike races, you see bikers lined up behind the lead guy.
这就是为什么在自行车比赛中，你会看到骑手们排在领头人后面。
I remember bending my head over as I was pedaling as hard as I could, and looking behind me, and yeah. I just saw this kind of white-and-black checkered jersey coming across to me, and that was Mike.
我记得我尽可能用力踩踏板时把头低下来，向后看，是的。我看到了这种黑白相间的格纹球衣越过我，那是迈克。
Mike Friedman. Ian knew who the favorites at this race were, and this Mike Friedman wasn't one of them.
迈克·弗里德曼（Mike Friedman）。伊恩知道这场比赛的热门选手是谁，而这个迈克·弗里德曼并不在其中。
And so I just sprinted as hard as I could. He would claw his way back to me, and I just couldn't believe it. He seemed so done, but he was just really tenacious. He just kept coming back.
所以我只是尽可能用力冲刺。他会竭尽全力追上我，我简直无法相信。他看起来已经精疲力竭了，但他真的非常顽强。他不断追赶上来。
Ian was worried now. If he kept the lead, blocking all of the wind for Mike, he was going to get tired. Mike might burst ahead and win. So Ian was like, let him get in front for a bit.
伊恩现在很担心。如果他保持领先，挡住迈克的所有风阻，他就会累坏。迈克可能会冲刺并赢下比赛。所以伊恩心想，让他领先一会吧。
I started coasting, and then we were kind of just coasting. And he would look back, and the group would be getting closer to catching us. And he said, you can win.
我开始滑行，然后我们基本上只是在滑行。他会向后看，大部队会离我们越来越近。他说，“你可以赢。”
You can win. Three words.
“你可以赢。”三个词。
I knew instantly what it meant. He means, if I stop attacking him and let him stay with me, and let him sit in my draft, then when we get to the finish line, he won't sprint me. He'll let me win the bike race.
我瞬间就知道那意味着什么。他的意思是，如果我停止攻击他，让他和我待在一起，让他坐在我的气流里，那么当我们到达终点线时，他不会冲刺超过我。他会让我赢得自行车比赛。
Now in cycling, this type of gentlemen's agreement happens all the time. Competitors will temporarily agree to a truce so they can conserve energy and stay ahead of the pack. It's a strategy. Sometimes this happens at the end, which could end up deciding who wins. Like hey, there's two of us here at the top. I won't sprint on you if you take on the wind resistance for me. We can beat everyone else. Ian went for it.
在自行车运动中，这种绅士协定经常发生。竞争者们会暂时同意停战，这样他们就可以保存体力并保持在领头位置。这是一种策略。有时这发生在最后，这最终决定了谁获胜。比如，嘿，我们在顶端有两个人。如果你为我承担风阻，我就不会向你冲刺。我们可以击败其他人。伊恩同意了。
I just put my head down and went as hard as I could. I mean, I felt like I was just going so fast, and we had a motorcycle referee that would follow the race. And they come up and give you time splits. They'll either just tell you, or sometimes they'll have a whiteboard that they'll write the gap between you and the chasers. And so they kept coming up, and it would be, you have 20 seconds. And then it was like 30 seconds, and then 40 seconds, and the gap just kept going out, and out, and out.
我只是低下头，尽我所能。我的意思是，我觉得我跑得太快了，我们有一名跟随比赛的摩托车裁判。他们会上来给你时间差。他们要么只是告诉你，有时他们会有一个白板，写下你和追赶者之间的差距。所以他们不断上来，说，你有20秒。然后是30秒，40秒，差距不断扩大，扩大，扩大。
I remember with one lap to go and just feeling so happy, like I'd already won the race. And then so we go around, and then we're coming towards the finish line. And we're getting ready to take the final left-hand turn to the finish. And I turned to him and I was like, yeah, you remember our deal, right? And then Mike just started sprinting. And I just remember watching him come by on my left, and my legs started cramping as we went up that hill.
我记得在还剩一圈时感到非常开心，好像我已经赢得了比赛。然后我们绕过去，正朝着终点线前进。我们正准备进行向终点的最后一次左转。我转过去对他说了声，是的，你记得我们的交易，对吧？然后迈克就开始冲刺。我只记得看着他从我的左侧冲过去，当我们上那座山时，我的腿开始抽筋。
And I was just like, I can't believe this is happening. It felt like this dream just all of a sudden kind of turned into a nightmare. And I didn't win the bike race.
我简直不敢相信这是真的。感觉这个梦突然变成了一场噩梦。我没有赢得自行车比赛。
Mike did. Mike won.
迈克赢了。迈克赢了。
Disbelief quickly turned to total rage. I was so upset. Remember riding up next to him, and hitting him on the back, and yelling something like, what the [BLEEP]?
不相信很快变成了彻底的愤怒。我太难过了。记得骑到他旁边，打他的后背，并大喊类似，“什么鬼（[BLEEP]）？”的话。
First place takes home a jersey with stars and stripes, like Captain America.
第一名带回一件有星星和条纹的球衣，就像美国队长一样。
I watched them put Mike's medal on, and then they gave him a jersey. And then, traditionally, everybody raises their arms on the podium after the national anthem plays. And I was standing right next to Mike, and I didn't-- I wouldn't hold his hand. I didn't raise my arm. And that was like the photo of the race.
我看着他们给迈克戴上奖牌，然后他们给了他一件球衣。然后，按照传统，国歌播放后，每个人都会在领奖台上举起双臂。我当时就站在迈克旁边，我没有——我不会握他的手。我没有举起我的手臂。那成了这场比赛的照片。
Ian was not having it. He immediately told the reporter what happened. He was like, Mike cheated. He cheated.
伊恩不打算接受这一点。他立即告诉记者发生了什么。他说，迈克作弊了。他作弊了。
His side of the story was that there was no deal, that I was just confused. When he said, you can win this race, he was like, no, no, no, no. What I was saying was if we work together, if you stop attacking me, you can win. Stop attacking me. Stop trying to get rid of me. You can win if you just keep pulling, and don't let this group behind catch us.
他的故事版本是根本没有交易，我只是搞错了。当他说“你可以赢得这场比赛”时，他是说，不，不，不，不。我想说的是，如果我们合作，如果你停止攻击我，你就能赢。停止攻击我。停止试图摆脱我。如果你继续拉动，别让后面的人追上我们，你就能赢。
As if to say, hey, man, you're doing well. You keep it up, you might even win this thing. I said you could win, not that I'd let you win. So life goes on. Ian races professionally for a bit, but gets injured and becomes a journalist. Of course, he covers cycling. Mike becomes an Olympian. The whole time, they're sort of circling each other's orbits, but avoiding crossing paths. And annoyingly, everyone in the racing world really likes Mike.
好像在说，嘿，伙计，你做得很好。你继续保持，甚至可能赢得比赛。我说的是你能赢，而不是我会让你赢。所以生活还要继续。伊恩在职业赛场待了一会儿，但受伤了，成为了一名记者。当然，他报道自行车运动。迈克成了奥运选手。在这期间，他们一直在彼此的轨道周围盘旋，但避免交集。而且烦人的是，赛车界的每个人都很喜欢迈克。
He had this nickname as like Meatball, and he had a blog, and there was a lot of love for Meatball. And I was a little bit resentful about that. I always thought, they don't know the real Mike. He's a cheater. And he goes back on his word. And I would tell people, or people would ask me about, what happened in that race? And I'd be like, well, Mike's a cheater. And they'd just be like, well, doesn't seem like something he would do. And then I'd be like, no, you don't know.
他有个绰号叫“肉丸”（Meatball），他有个博客，人们对肉丸有很多喜爱。我对此感到有点怨恨。我一直认为，他们不知道真实的迈克。他是个骗子。他违背了他的承诺。我会告诉人们，或者人们会问我关于那场比赛发生了什么，我会说，好吧，迈克是个骗子。他们会说，好吧，这看起来不像他会做的事。然后我会说，不，你不了解。
People would sort of look at me sideways when I was like, I hate Mike Friedman. They'd be like, nobody hates Mike Friedman. What are you talking about?
当我说我讨厌迈克·弗里德曼时，人们会斜眼看我。他们会说，没人讨厌迈克·弗里德曼。你在说什么？
That's like saying you hate Mr. Rogers, right?
那就像说你讨厌罗杰斯先生一样，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
So as time passes, this race stays like a thorn in Ian's side.
所以随着时间的推移，这场比赛一直像一根刺扎在伊恩心里。
I realize saying that sounds like a high school football player talking about competing in the state title game, or whatever else. And then I totally get how ridiculous and small that sounds as an adult. But it's weird. It's just weird how you cling to those things.
我意识到这么说听起来像是一个高中橄榄球运动员在谈论参加州冠军赛或其他什么。我完全明白作为一个成年人这么说有多么荒谬和微小。但很奇怪。坚持那些事情真是奇怪。
Then one day, about 15 years later, Ian's covering a race in Colorado near where Mike lived. He's on the tour bus hanging out. And then--
然后有一天，大约15年后，伊恩在科罗拉多州迈克家附近报道一场比赛。他在巡回巴士上闲逛。然后——
One of the guys on the bus was like, oh, I'm going to give Mike a call and see if he'll come to the start line and hang out with us on the bus before we start. And Mike came onto the bus. We didn't even look at each other, and then he left. And then when he came back, I was standing outside the bus. And he had a tray of coffees, and he handed me one.
巴士上的一个人说，哦，我要给迈克打个电话，看看他能不能在我们开始前过来起点线跟我们在巴士上待一会儿。迈克上了巴士。我们甚至没看对方一眼，然后他就离开了。当他回来时，我正站在巴士外面。他端着一盘咖啡，给了我一杯。
And I think he was just like, I just want to talk to you about that day. I think about that race all the time. And I was like, man, me too.
我想他只是说，我只想和你谈谈那天的事。我一直想着那场比赛。我说，伙计，我也是。
And I remember seeing his lower lip shaking, just shaking.
我记得看到他的下唇在颤抖，在颤抖。
And that is Mike Friedman. That day on the bus, Mike didn't fully fess up and apologize. For Mike, it's complicated. Here's how he remembers those final moments of the race.
那正是迈克·弗里德曼。在那天巴士上，迈克并没有完全坦白并道歉。对于迈克来说，这很复杂。这是他记忆中比赛最后时刻的样子。
But I wasn't even thinking. I was just, man, we made this left-hand turn, and the finish line is right within sight, 250 meters. And before I knew it, I was sprinting. Even going up to the line, I knew what I was doing was wrong, but I couldn't stop.
但我当时根本没思考。我只是，伙计，我们完成了这个左转，终点线就在视线内，250米。在我意识到之前，我就在冲刺了。即使冲向终点线，我也知道我在做错事，但我停不下来。
Do you know why you did what you did, or have a better understanding of why you did it?
你知道你为什么做你所做的事，或者更好地理解你为什么那么做吗？
Well, I was 17 years old at the time. So I just-- yeah. I don't know. It just is kind of one of those things that I don't have an answer. You know, I try my best, but I don't always do my best kind of thing. It wasn't preplanned. It wasn't done in a way to be nefarious. It wasn't, I'm going to tell this guy I'm going to do this and then sprint. It wasn't done in that way. It wasn't done that way at all. That's it. You know, that's it.
好吧，我当时才17岁。所以我只是——是的。我不知道。这只是那种我没有答案的事情之一。你知道，我尽了最大努力，但我并不总是做到最好。这不是预谋的。它不是以那种邪恶的方式完成的。它不是，我要告诉这个人我要这样做，然后冲刺。它不是那样完成的。它根本不是那样完成的。就是这样。你知道，就是这样。
That's the only time I've ever cheated, ever, at a bicycle race, ever.
这是我在自行车比赛中唯一一次，有史以来，唯一一次作弊。
He immediately regretted it.
他立即后悔了。
Did it change how you saw yourself as an athlete, as a competitor?
这改变了你作为一名运动员、作为一名竞争者的自我形象吗？
It did change how I saw myself. This is just-- I don't have anything else like that, that I can definitively say affected me the way that this had. That was the one thing that I knew that I had done wrong.
它确实改变了我对自己的看法。这只是——除了这个，我没有其他任何事情可以明确地说像这样影响了我。这是我知道我做错的一件事。
It ate at him. He didn't race for two years. Mike didn't even tell anyone for a really long time. Fessing up that he cheated would mean that he was just that-- a cheater, not a kid who lost himself for a minute in a race.
这一直在啃噬他。他有两年没比赛。迈克很长一段时间没告诉任何人。承认他作弊意味着他就是那样的人——一个骗子，而不是一个在比赛中迷失了一分钟的孩子。
Dude, I didn't admit that this happened until I was with someone that I wanted to marry. And then there was one other person that I told while I was drunk, and he's my best friend.
伙计，我直到和我想结婚的人在一起时才承认这件事发生过。然后还有一个人是我喝醉时告诉的，他是我最好的朋友。
It never met as much to anyone else as it did to him, but he couldn't let it go. He thought about it for years. After his cycling career was done, his life sort of tanked. His marriage ended, hit bottom. He was living in a camper on his friend's land when he realized he wanted to reach out to Ian, that he missed his opportunity on the bus a year back. Here's Ian.
这件事对任何人来说都没有对他意义重大，但他无法释怀。他思考了多年。他的自行车生涯结束后，他的生活基本上陷入了低谷。他的婚姻结束了，跌到了谷底。他住在朋友土地上的露营车里，当时他意识到他想联系伊恩，他错过了之前一年在巴士上的机会。这是伊恩的观点。
He was moving back to Colorado, and he was driving back. And he called me, and that's when he said, yeah, you're right. It was a deal. And I'm sorry that I crossed the finish line first, that I didn't hold up my end of the bargain.
他要搬回科罗拉多，正在开车回去。他给我打了电话，那时候他说，是的，你是对的。那是场交易。我很抱歉我第一个越过终点线，没有履行我的承诺。
Mike also wants to give Ian the jersey, the Captain America one. He'd stuffed it deep in a drawer all these years. So they agreed to meet up.
迈克也想把球衣——那件美国队长的球衣——给伊恩。这些年来，他把它深深塞在抽屉里。所以他们同意见面。
He drives this really like revved-up-- I think it's a Jeep, or a pickup truck, or something. And you could hear it rumbling down the street, like rum-rum-rum-rum-rum. You could hear him pull up, and I was kind of nervous. And he came up, and he was holding the jersey, and he gave it to me right away. He looked me in the eyes, and he said, sorry. And I said, thank you.
他开着一辆看起来非常轰鸣的——我想是吉普车，或者皮卡车之类的。你可以听到它在街上轰鸣，像“隆-隆-隆-隆-隆”。你可以听到他开过来，我有点紧张。他走过来，手里拿着球衣，立刻把它给了我。他看着我的眼睛说，“对不起。”我说，“谢谢。”
He had talked about, like I think he had even called the governing body, and asked them if there's any way that the actual results could be changed. And yeah. He was just like, every effort to make it right. I was just like, wow. When does that ever happen in someone's life? I don't even know when I've ever done that, just made something that I did wrong right, decades later.
他谈到，我想他甚至打电话给管理机构，询问是否有任何方法可以更改实际结果。是的。他就像是，每一种努力都为了让它变得正确。我只是想，“哇”。这种情况在一个人的一生中何时会发生？我甚至不知道我什么时候做过那样的事，仅仅是纠正了我做错的事，几十年后。
This event set off by a few words had just ballooned and ballooned in their heads for about 15 years, even though, in the grand scheme of things, this race didn't matter. It's not like it was the reason Mike made it, or the thing that ended Ian's career. And fixing it took something that's so simple-- three words. You were right.
这件由几句话引发的事件在他们脑海中膨胀了大约15年，尽管从宏观来看，这场比赛并不重要。它不像它是迈克成功的理由，或结束伊恩职业生涯的事情。而纠正它需要一些非常简单的事情——三个词。“你是对的。”
Jared Marcelle. His reporting can be heard on the podcast Caught from WNYC. Ian Dille, the racer who got cheated out of his victory, wrote about this in Bicycle Magazine. That's how we heard about the story. The other racer, Mike Friedman, now runs a non-profit teaching kids about bikes, called Pedaling Minds.
杰瑞德·马塞尔。他的报道可以在WNYC的播客《Caught》中听到。伊恩·迪尔，那位被骗去胜利的赛车手，在《自行车杂志》上写了关于这件事的报道。这就是我们听到这个故事的方式。另一位赛车手，迈克·弗里德曼，现在经营着一个非营利组织，向孩子们传授自行车知识，叫《Pedaling Minds》。
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu. The people who put our show together includes Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Neil Drumming, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Raimando, Ben Feiglin, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Ship, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editors are Susan Burton and David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由黛安·吴（Diane Wu）制作。组成我们节目的团队包括：本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、贾勒特·弗洛伊德（Jarrett Floyd）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·纳尔逊（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷曼多（Katherine Raimando）、本·费格林（Ben Feiglin）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Ship）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和大卫·克滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Special thanks to Dave Ptolemy Slocum, Chuck Long, Chris Bateman, David Goldenberg, Veronica Simmons, Astrid Lange, Brendan Copley, and Michelle Solomon.
特别感谢戴夫·托勒密·斯洛克姆（Dave Ptolemy Slocum）、查克·朗（Chuck Long）、克里斯·贝特曼（Chris Bateman）、大卫·戈尔登伯格（David Goldenberg）、维罗妮卡·西蒙斯（Veronica Simmons）、阿斯特丽德·兰格（Astrid Lange）、布伦丹·科普利（Brendan Copley）和米歇尔·所罗门（Michelle Solomon）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I called him earlier today. When I called him, I don't know, he was at the gym in the middle of his sprint intervals.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所 PRX 分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，我今天早些时候给他打了电话。当我打电话给他时，不知道，他正在健身房进行短跑间歇训练。
I mean, I can't really-- like, I mean, man, the timing of this.
我是说，我真的无法——我是说，伙计，这真是太巧了。
Actually, real-life Torey just had back surgery this week. Feel better, OK? I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
其实，现实生活中的托雷这周刚做了背部手术。早日康复，好吗？我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。